YOU KNOW WHAT, WHY DON'T WE
CHECK IN WITH THE
PRESIDENTIAL RACE?
WAS THERE BIG NEWS TODAY FOR
REPUBLICANS OR MAYBE ME?
>> THE RACE FOR THE WHITE
HOUSE KICKING OFF THIS
MORNING, TEXAS SENATOR TED
CRUZ ANNOUNCING ON TWITTER
OVERNIGHT THAT HE IS NOW
RUNNING FOR PRESIDENT.
>> THE 2016 PRESIDENTIAL
SEASON IS NOW UNDER WAY.
>> LET THE RACE BEGIN.
>> WAIT, NOW IT BEGINS THE
RACE?
WHAT HAVE YOU BEEN DOING FOR
THE PAST 18 MONTHS?
WHAT ARE WE SCAMPING AROUND
THESE PEOPLE WHILE THEY WERE
BRUNCHING AT BILLIONAIRE CLUBS
AND DEEP-THROATING EVERY IOWA
PIG FARMER WITHIN
YODELING DISTANCE.
(LAUGHTER)
THAT SENTENCE HAD MORE FUNNY
WORDS PER SENTENCE IN IT.
DEEP-THROATING PIG FARMERS,
YODELLING, YOU'RE NOT GOING TO
FIND A BETTER FUNNY SENTENCE
THAN THAT.
BUT ALL RIGHT, I GUESS, IT
STARTED TODAY WITH CRUZ'S
ANNOUNCEMENT.
VIRGINIA'S LEGENDARY LIBERTY
UNIVERSITY, THE CONSERVATIVE
CHRISTIAN SCHOOL FOUNDED BY
JERRY FALWELL.
STAKES WERE HIGH.
BUT CRUZ'S LEVEL OF PREPARATION,
HIGHER.
>> CRUZ AND HIS FAMILY DID A
WALK-THROUGH AT LIBERTY
UNIVERSITY WHERE HE WILL
GIVE HIS ANNOUNCEMENT SPEECH
TODAY.
EVEN PRACTICING THE WAVING
AND KISSING.
>> I MAY OWE MITT ROMNEY AN
APOLOGY.
EVEN THE MITT ROMNEY TRON
3,000 DIDN'T HAVE TO
REHEARSE WAVING AND KISSING.
>> OKAY, JON. OKAY. THAT IS NOT
FAIR AT ALL.
>> Jon: I MEAN, COME ON.
>> JON, THAT IS NOT FAIR AT ALL.
>> SAM AND JASON WHAT DO YOU
MEAN?
>> YEAH, JON, LISTEN. NO, NO, NO
PLEASE.
(CHEERS AND APPLAUSE)
DO YOU REALLY-- JON, DO
YOU REALLY THINK KISSING
BETWEEN MARRIED PEOPLE JUST
HAPPENS NATURALLY?
>> I GUESS I DID. I JUST THOUGHT
--
>> OH MY GOD, NO.
>> IT TAKES YEARS OF
PRACTICE.
ALL RIGHT, SHOULD WE DO IT?
LET'S SHOW HIM.
>> YEAH. OKAY.
>> Jon: OH.
>> SHE ALWAYS MESSES IT UP. HERE
IT'S LIKE THIS.
>> OKAY.
>> Jon: NO. HOW LONG YOU HAVE
TWO BEEN MARRIED?
>> I DON'T KNOW, LIKE A
THOUSAND YEARS.
>> Jon: ALL RIGHT.
>> YEAH, WE SHOULD REALLY
PRACTICE SECOND BASE.
>> OH OKAY.
>> YEAH, YEAH. KAY. OH, IT FEELS
GOOD.
>> NOT EASY, JON, NOT EASY.
>> Jon: THANK YOU, SAM BEE
AND JASON JONES, EVERYBODY.
(APPLAUSE)
HAVE THEY BEEN THERE MAKING OUT
THE WHOLE TIME AND I
DIDN'T EVEN NOTICE IT?
AND THEN ITS WITH TIME FOR THE
BIG SPEECH.
LET'S SEE HOW THE LIBERTY
UNIVERSITY STUDENTS WELCOMED
THE SENATOR.
WHOOO, THE EXCITEMENT, THE
PASSION.
THE RAND PAUL T-SHIRTS.
(LAUGHTER)
(APPLAUSE)
ALL RIGHT, NOW THAT-- THAT
IS SOMEWHAT AWESOME.
(LAUGHTER)
BUT COME ON, GUYS,
DON'T SHOW UP AT THE
SENATOR'S BIG DAY WEARING
THE OTHER TEAM'S JERSEY.
IF YOU DON'T WANT TO BE
THERE, JUST DON'T BE THERE.
>> THE STUDENTS WERE REQUIRED TO
BE HERE.
IT IS A WEEKLY CONVOCATION THAT
STUDENTS HAVE.
>> Jon: THEN CARRY ON.
OF COURSE NO CAMPAIGN
LAUNCH WOULD BE COMPLETE
WITHOUT SOME WEIRDLY THIRD
PERSON AUTOBIOGRAPHY.
>> IMAGINE ANOTHER TEENAGE
BOY, BEING RAISED IN HOUSTON,
HEADING OFF TO SCHOOL, OVER
A THOUSAND MILES AWAY FROM
HOME AT A PLACE WHERE HE
KNEW NOBODY.
WHERE HE WAS ALONE AN SCARED.
>> DUDE.
YOU WENT TO PRINCETON.
LIKE I MEAN, DON'T MAKE IT SOUND
LIKE YOU GOT FORCED ON TO
THE TRAIN TO HOGWARTS.
ALTHOUGH THAT WOULD HAVE
BEEN THE EASIEST SORTING HAT
EVER.
SLYTHERIN, SLYTHERIN IT IS.
BUT-- CRUZ, CRUZ LOOKED TO
THE FUTURE.
>> I WANT TO ASK EACH OF YOU
TO IMAGINE, IMAGINE A
PRESIDENT WHO SAYS I WILL
HONOR THE CONSTITUTION.
IMAGINE ABOLISHING THE IRS.
INSTEAD OF A GOVERNMENT,
THAT SEIZES YOUR E-MAILS,
AND YOUR CELL PHONES,
IMAGINE A FEDERAL GOVERNMENT
THAT PROTECTS THE PRIVACY
RIGHTS OF EVERY AMERICAN.
>> Jon: WE GET IT, YOU ARE A
FAN OF JOHN LENNON AND SMALL
GOVERNMENT.
YOU'RE A SMALL GOVERNMENT
CONSERVATIVE FREEDOM GOOD,
BIG BROTHER BAD.
WHICH MAKES THE NEXT PART OF
THE SPEECH KIND OF
UNEXPECTED.
>> I'M GOING TO ASK YOU TO
BREAK A RULE HERE TODAY.
>> Jon: I WANT YOU TO TURN
TO THE PERSON TO YOUR RIGHT
AND SODOMIZE THEM.
>> AND TO TAKE OUT YOUR CELL
PHONES.
>> Jon: OH, ALL RIGHT. TAKE OUT
YOUR CELL PHONE.
NOT AS REBELIOUS AS I
THOUGHT BUT OKAY.
I HATE TO BREAK IT TO YOU
BUT THOSE KIDS CELL PHONES
WERE ALREADY OUT.
I'M NOT SAYING YOU'RE
BORING.
LET'S JUST SAY YOU'RE MORE
INTERESTING ON SNAPCHAT.
BUT THE POINT IS THIS-- YOU
WERE SAYING IMAGINE, YOU KNOW,
THEY DON'T GET YOUR RECORDS,
WHAT ARE THESE LIBERTY LOVERS
SUPPOSED TO DO.
>> TAKE OUT YOUR CELL
PHONES.
TEXT THE WORD CONSTITUTION
TO THE NUMBER 33733.
ONCE AGAIN, TEXT
CONSTITUTION TO 33733.
>> Jon: THE THING IS, HE
NEVER EXPLAINED WHAT 33733
IS.
HE JUST WANTED THEM TO TEXT
IT.
SO LET ME CLARIFY THIS A
LITTLE BIT.
STUDENTS AT LIBERTY
UNIVERSITY WERE REQUIRED TO
ATTEND A PARTISAN POLITICAL
SPEECH WHERE A SMALL
GOVERNMENT CONSERVATIVE WHO
HAD JUST PROMISED HE WOULD
RESPECT PRIVACY RIGHTS TOLD
THEM IF THEY CARED ABOUT
FREEDOM, TEXT YOUR
INFORMATION TO A MYSTERIOUS
ADDRESS THAT COLLECTS YOUR
CELL PHONE NUMBER FOR
UNDISCLOSED PURPOSES.
IMAGINE ALL THE PEOPLE,
WE'LL BE RIGHT BACK.